direkt hinter dem Checkpoint am
Ortseingang von razon haben wir uns mit
Natalia rodrigres verabredet sie ist
Soldatin auf dem Weg in die
Gerichtsmedizin die Leiche eines
gefallenen Kameraden abholen und nach
Odessa bringen
wie oft machen sie so was jetzt sehr oft
manchmal auch täglich
wie schwer ist es
wissen sie der Mensch gewöhnt sich an
alles aber das ist etwas woran man sich
nicht gewöhnen kann
Natalias Job ist gefährlich schon allein
die Fahrt durch die Frontstadt Hessen
auch Natalia mit ihrem improvisierten
Leichenwagen ist schon unter Beschuss
geraten
die Russen schießen auch auf tote
Soldaten sie sehen ja sie haben sogar
die Leichenhalle beschossen die Russen
Schießen auf alles Friedhöfe leichenhain
zivile Städte
auch das Gebäude der Gerichtsmedizin in
Hassan wird immer wieder getroffen die
Kollegen kennt Natalia inzwischen gut
hier bekommt sie die Papiere weiß jetzt
wen sie die nächsten Stunden bei sich im
Auto hat
er wurde im Jahr 1980 geboren ich hole
es der hieß ab
wissen Sie wo er getötet wurde in der
nähe
ich weiß wo es passiert ist aber genau
das kann ich leider nicht sagen
Natalia macht sich fertig der Leichnam
muss ins Auto
ja seine Familie wartet auf ihn das ist
jetzt aber keine schnelle Prozedur wir
bringen den Leichnam hin und dann wird
mit dem einberufungsamt entschieden wann
das Begräbnis stattfindet und erst dann
wird der Leichnam an die Familie
geliefert im Sarg und entsprechend
angezogen
im Transporter liegt ein weißer
Leichensack die nächsten Stunden wird
Natalia mit ihm allein sein
ich bin keine militärfrau ich bin
Rechtsanwältin ich war es ich habe ein
ganz normales Leben geführt wie wir alle
aber als der Krieg angefangen hat war
das gewöhnliche Leben vorbei
Natalia ist Mutter von drei Kindern als
der Krieg ausbrach hat sie sich
freiwillig gemeldet einer muss diesen
Job ja machen sagt sie
wenn du diese Funktion erfüllst die
Gefallenen transportierst wenn du
verstehst dass es deine Waffenbrüder
sind dann verstehst du dass es das
verlorene Leben deines Volkes ist jedes
Leben ist die ganze Welt
Natalia weiß nie was sie erwartet jeder
Tag ist anders manchmal liefert sie die
Leichen in Odessa bloß ab manchmal
warten dort schon die Angehörigen der
Toten
das Schlimmste ist wenn die Verwandten
bereits wissen wann wir kommen und an
der Leichenhalle warten oder schon in
der Leichenhalle und darum bitten den
Sack zu öffnen weil sie hineinschauen
möchten und das ist schlimm weil der
Zustand der Leiche manchmal so ist dass
es besser wäre dass nie im Leben zu
sehen bis dann
jedes Soldaten Begräbnis wird von den
Streitkräften organisiert und bezahlt
wie viele ukrainische Soldaten gefallen
sind dazu gibt es keine offiziellen
Zahlen
[Musik]
das ist der Krieg der Kampf für unsere
Freiheit und die gibt es nie umsonst es
gibt ein ukrainisches Sprichwort gratis
ist nur die Sklaverei auf einem Friedhof
in Odessa hört das Meer der Fahnen gar
nicht mehr auf jede Fahne gehört zum
Grab eines gefallenen Soldaten
ungefähr anderthalb Jahren hier da gab
es hier 10 oder 12 Gräber und dann kam
ich heute alles voller Soldaten ich habe
Tränen in meinen Augen wegen unserer
Jungs sie sind 20 bis 30 Jahre alt sie
sterben haben das Leben nie richtig
kennengelernt Mütter begraben ihre Söhne
Frauen begraben ihre Ehemänner Kinder
bleiben als weisen zurück
wir wollen dass dieser Krieg schnell
endet dass unsere Kinder in Frieden
leben können
olessias Kind lebt nicht mehr Alexie hat
sich zu Kriegsbeginn freiwillig gemeldet
er starb bei einem Kampfeinsatz an der
südlichen Front
er ist am 7.8 während eines
Kampfeinsatzes umgekommen er überquerte
den niebro er transportierte Jungs und
es gab einen direkten Treffer in den
Fluss
acht Jungs keiner ist am Leben geblieben
mein Kind ist für unsere Freiheit
gestorben
stationiert direkt an der Front dort wo
gerade die Gegend Offensive der Ukraine
läuft mit hohen Verlusten
ich will verteidigen und vorne sein um
alles zu tun was von mir abhängt und der
Tod nahm ihn mit sich in diesem Jahr
wäre er 23 geworden
auf dem Friedhof von Odessa gibt es an
diesem Morgen zwei Beerdigungen und es
werden weitere folgen die Gräber werden
gerade ausgehoben
das tut mir weh ich sehe diese Gräber
ich sehe dass sie alle sehr junge Männer
sind das sind meine gleichaltrigen
diejenigen die Anfang der 2000er geboren
wurden es tut mir einfach weh Brüste
Natalia kümmert sich derweil um die
Details der Beerdigung von Sally
shayowski alles spricht sie genau mit
der Familie ab Tod und Trauer überall
dabei sind sie sich nach Frieden ich
hoffe sehr darauf dass dieser Krieg
endet jeder Mensch der hier lebt hofft
dass der Krieg zu Ende geht
das Schlimmste steht Natalia noch bevor
die Begegnung mit den Angehörigen bei
der Beerdigung erst dort sagt sie
begreife sie den Verlust